ゴールに向かうからゴールは達成したら
パッションダウンになるんだよ。パーパス
です。ゴールではなく目的にもう1回
セットアップし直すってことだと思うよ。
金の稼ぎ方で終わるんじゃなくて使い方
まで行ったら本物だなと思う。青木サの
人生額100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今回のテーマは仕事へのまネり感でして、ま、達成したのになぜか虚しい。達成後の虚無感とどう向き合うのかというテーマでメッセージをいただけますでしょうか?
[音楽]
俺虚無感じたことないんだよね。難しい。自分が経験したことないこと言えないわな。な、何なんだろう。多分ね、浅いんだと思うよ。
仕事の深みが分かってないんだと思うよ。
表面的なやっつけ仕事してるからそうなる
んだよ。やっぱりね、こだわりじゃないの
?いや、だから俺経営者で赤字ばっか出し
てるやつってやめた方がいいと思うよ。何
考えてんのって話だよ。あと勉強しない
やつな。僕はやっぱり
健全に金持ちにもなりたいと思ったし、
やっぱり卓越したいと思ったし、そこそこ
ほどほどじゃ嫌なんだよ。だ、1筋の道を
歩んでいると、1筋の道を歩んでいる人に
出会うんですよ。そして仲良くなるんです
よ。打ち込んで代償払った人にしかわから
ない共感するものがある。みんな前向き
ですよ。一生懸命生きてますよ。うん。だ
からなんだろう。そのまんねりなんていう
のはダメだよ。しっかり生徒。いや、本当
にそう思うよ、俺。うん。なんだろうな。
いや、それすごいね、僕にとってはありえ
ない世界なんだよね。響いちゃうんですよ
。矢沢さんだってきっとロックンロール
否定されたらカチンと来ると思うよ。お前
何をロックが分かってんだよって。多分僕
はだから能力発の専門家だからまネりとは
正反対の世界生きてる世界じゃん。だ
やっぱり尖ってるんですよ、そこは。33
年同じ3日間の研修やり続けてきたわけだ
よ。今経営者対象に特別講座でもう70回
。今度でね、その前700回やったからね
。スタンダードコースの時は頂点の道口座
1回とも同じ講座ありません。28年連続
開催毎月1回から2回3回やったんだから
700回その間に子供も生まれ父親の高い
ね父親が死に
母親も死に海のね私を生んでくれた海の親
も死にも死に娘が生まれ息子が生まれ
いろんなことがありました。33年
アチーメントは今期過去最高業績です。
資本金500万、社員5名で作った会社、
合期70億の研修会社で壁を破りましたよ
ね。経利益も30億にもう近い。9月の末
に、え、決算迎えて最終の締めになる
けれども、でも僕は目先の忖徳を追ってき
たわけじゃないんですよ。僕の研修まず3
日間のうち午前中出ただけで大体経営者
しびれるんですよ。でもね、昔1人ね、
午前中で帰ったやつがいたな。お、それ俺
追いかけてってうちの社員に金買いさせた
んだけど、それなんで帰ったかつうと、
それボンボン。超ボンボンで帝国ホテルに
暮らしてるらしいんだよ。ほれ。で、俺が
ね、いわゆる父親、容女で早く社会出て、
ま、今俺はね、事業創造大学院大学の大学
院生一応は形上は大学院生だし、客員教授
でもなってんだけど、当時は中卒ですって
言ったもんだから午前中ね、中卒って聞い
ただけでこいつの話聞いてるね、聞いて
られるかと思ったらしいよ。で、さっさと
帰っちゃったの。要するに学歴に対して超
変なパラダイム持ってるやつなのよ。でも
当時でも俺どうだろうな、経常利益でも
あの当時でも5億とか6億しか出して
なかったかもしんない。俺ずっとKOやっ
てきて基本的には毎年毎年グラフ伸ばして
きたからね。コロナの時だけだから下がっ
たのはだって2回2期連続下がったら口座
やめるって言ってきたわけだから2回連続
で下がったことないでこれから100億の
壁を破って次の台で300億ね、そして
500億と目指しててくれると思いますよ
。数字じゃないんだよ。世の中に求め
られる価値ある商品サービスを提供して
いく。それがだんだんだんだん日本国内
だけじゃなくてアジアとかま、優秀な社員
を採用することによって本当に会社が
どんどんどんどんこうやって発展していく
。僕の会社っていう認識ではみんなで
アチーブメントという組織体を通して個人
ではできないことをするために組織を作り
、この組織によって社会に貢献していこう
というこだわり
分かるでしょ?このパッションだから
まんネりって聞くと腹立つわけ
何考えてんだお前はみたいになっちゃう。
俺にはありえない世界なのよ。ありがとう
ございます。うん。
ちなみにその、ま、青木社長とはすごく遠い存在だと思うんですが、そのどうしてもでもやっぱり仕事の真んネり感を感じていたりとか、大きな目標を達成した後に、ま、虚無感を感じてしまって、ま、どうしたらいいんだろうと思ってる人に
アドバイスされるとしたらどうなるほど。分かった。今天から降りてきました。それはね、パーです。
ゴールではなくゴールに向かうからゴール
は達成したらパッションダウンになるんだ
よ。でもパーパスってゴールの先にある
目的だから目的にもう1回セットアップ
し直すってことだと思うよ。誰のために何
のためになぜでもっと言うと本質的には
払いめて自分をこのようにま、両親という
よりもお袋が払いめてこのようにせを与え
てくれたわけじゃん。なんだろう。それ
だけの大下を払って命がけで生んでくれた
ことに対する恩返しせなあかん。親父だっ
てでも一生懸命働いて、ま、うちの親父は
色々所持けれども、でもやっぱり親父は
親父なりに精一杯生きたんだと思う。
やっぱり両親があって今があるだ。僕は
やっぱり自慢の息子でありたいと思ったよ
な。俺頑張ったよ。だからパーパスだから
今で言うとパーパスって自分の命の花を
咲かせるっていうか。かっこよく生きてき
たいじゃん。自分の人生も嫌じゃん。中途
半端なのだ。そういう意味では自己愛って
いうかさ、自分の人生1回限りのこの人生
与えられた命をせっかくだったら
思いっきりできるとこまでやってみたいん
じゃないの感じかな。さ、パーパスにもう
1回セットアップする。それが今天から
降りてきたアドバイスかもしれない。はい
、ありがとうございます。その社長がその
多くの方を見ていらっしゃる中でその
大きな目標を達成された後にま感を感じな
ん
特性だったりとかあとはそもそもその
真んネり化しつつあることに本人が気づい
てない場合もあったりするのかなと思っ
たりするんですけれどもう
だから基本的には心志しがないんだよ
自分中心なんだよ
パッションダウンになっちゃうんす
心志しがあったらパッションダムなんか
ならないもん。俺今回本当マジにまた
すんごいパワーもらったよ。あの渡辺美き
さんがやってる公域財団でそういう個人も
やってるんでそこのちょっとサポートし
たりして縁があって僕もパーニャちゃんっ
てねずっと里親をしてきたカンボジアの子
なんだけどね個人の子なんですよ。
お父さん刑務所に入っててお母さんは
ある中で死んじゃった。小学校の時から
ずっとあの支えてきた子が16歳になって
今回日本に招いて彼女
のそのを日本に招いたこともそうだし、
それからもう1つあのカンボジアの子が
高校生夢アワードでプレゼンしたんですよ
。その中でやっぱり教育っていうことの
意味を彼女は語ったんだよ。いわゆる
カンボジアは学ぶ図書館もなく少ないし、
クメール語で読める本の数も少ないわけよ
。だ、俺もっと
頑張って図書館も作ってあげたいし、今
まで3つ一応ね、学校起造してきたんだ
けどね。あと7つ校舎作ろうと。ま、それ
はまあ、前決めてたんだけど、なんか
頑張る理由ってそういうことなんじゃない
の?自分が食べることだとかな、いい生活
するなんてある程度もうすぐできちゃう
じゃん。そうじゃなくて、私はやっぱり
教育という視点で、ま、出版だから僕は
本当にあの、儲かる儲かないから考えたら
多分人口も少ないしカンボジアで出版社営
してもないかもしんないけどいや、俺やり
たいなと思ってで、クメール語でいっぱい
本出してあげて、まずはスンク&
グローリッチのね、権利も一応オッケー
もらったんで、ナポレヒル団からなんかさ
、そういう意味ではこう微力ながら少しで
もなんか人の役
に立つことができたらなんかかっこつけてるわけじゃないけど頑張る理由になるよね。だから心志しがあればパワー与えられるんじゃないかなっていうのが、ま、本音ですね、僕の。うん。
ありがとうございます。
あの、今お話いただいたところにもあると思うんですけれども、そのパスや心志しを磨き続ける、高め続けるためにできることって何かありますか?
[音楽]
まあ、1
つは僕はやっぱ渡辺美ミきさんと付き合って友達になったことによって啓されたような。だ、自分のよりも大きな器を持っている心志しのあるやっぱり本物の人間と付き合うことだと思うわ。付き合うってか縁ができたらいいね。
僕はミきさんと出会って、彼のが僕より
年下なんですよ。はるかに僕より大きな
転し持って頑張ってるよね。彼夢って言う
けれども本当すごいと思う。夜け石に水
だって言われ、周りからね、言われる
らしいんだよ。いいじゃないかよと。
焼け石でいいじゃないかって開き直ってる
もんね。そうで350も学校作ったんだよ
。事実すごいよ。育文官夢学園で学校経し
てる。自分校長までやってんだもん。いや
、俺はできない。学校まではできない。
もうさやかだけど一応さやかだけど10校
ぐらいの学校作るぐらいはできる。図書館
はできるかな。うん。今一応ね、
カンボジアにも視野作ったし。いやあ、で
もすごいと思うだ。もっと早く彼と出会っ
てたらもうちょっと違うパワーでできたの
かもしんない。やっぱ僕は出会うべくして
出会ったんだけどやっぱ60になって
出会ってるからね。60から出会った人で
社会貢献してる人ってみんな本物ですよ。
フォーバルの大久保さんにしてもそうだし
政治家でもそうですね。やっぱり一流の人
はみんな心志しを持ってるし誰かのために
頑張ってるわ。自分だけでなくて。だから
アンドリーカーネギのやっぱり研究を最近
し始めてね、一歩深く研究して分かったの
はやっぱりその金の稼ぎ方で終わるんじゃ
なくて使い方まで行ったら本物だなと思う
。9割捧げちゃったんだもあの人。僕もだ
からもっと捧げれる人間になりたいと思っ
てます。この人はなんかすごいパワフル
なったのよ。いい友達持つとパワフルに
なるね。
やっぱりパーパスに生き
るっていうことなんじゃないかと。究極
目的を明確にして目標ではなく目標は達成
したらパッションダウンになっちゃうから
また目標探さなきゃいけないみたいな。だ
パーパスってのはやっぱ北極性のような
もので北半球どの国からも同じ場所に
見える。そういうやっぱりこう目的に生き
るっていうことが
、ま、僕自身がそういう生き方を今してる
ので、自分自身の経験からはそういう助言
になるのかなね。皆さんと共に本当に良い
人生を生きていきたいと思います。よかっ
たらね、チャンネル登録もしていただき
たいですし、それはコメント欄にも
コメントお願いします。また次回の
YouTubeで会いましょう。よろしく
お願いします。ありがとうございます。
うん。俺こな間だアザブ10番でね、あの
すごい美味しいお寿司屋さんに行ったの。
いやあ、すごいなんだろうな。啓発され
ましたね。大将に。ま、中島津さんって
いうね、Jイリースというプライムの社長
。え、第71代日本年会の回答。彼に紹介
されて、ま、かなりとね、ちょうどあの
ラジオの番組が最終
収録で最初に3年前に出てもらったのも土
さんで最終回っていうことでその収録が
あったんでそのお礼も兼ねてま藤永さんっ
ていうねお寿司屋さんに連れてってくれた
んだけどこだわってたね。
いや、僕はそこで何を思ったかって言うと
ね、寿司職人、日本全国人どれぐらいいる
んだろうな。これ調べたことないけどさ、
まあ、多分何万人かはいると思うんだよ。
何千人ってわけじゃないから。そ、何万人
いる寿司職人でなんで自分の寿司作りに
こだわれないやがいっぱいいるんだろうっ
てことよね。だから僕が通ってるとこって
そのこだわりの上位からなんですよ。
そして今回その藤井長さんに行って思った
のはやっぱり今までこだわってたなと思っ
てた職人よりももっと強いこだわりのある
職人に出会っちゃうとここで張り変わる
わけだよね。そうするとこの強い職人の
ところのなんだろうに通うことになるわけ
じゃん。ま、会員性のお寿司屋さんで私は
、ま、寿司さんの信用があったんで、一応
会員にはしてもらえたんだけれども
こだわりなんだと思うよ。うん。でも昔超
有名なすごいそのミシュラン取ってる寿司
やって言ったことあんのねな。すごい有名
なところで。でも藤長さんのところ感動し
なかったよね。すごい年を取った職人さん
が握ってくれていると。その年齢に
びっくりしたっていうかな。90代で握っ
てるわけだから。それはすごいと思った。
うん。やっぱ藤永さんのこだわりがすごい
。で、おっしゃったのは狂器狂器ね、狂っ
たような狂器に近いこだわりが持てない
ような職人は本物じゃないって言いました
よ。そうなんだと思う。1番最初にね、
まずトロから来たよね。これ名刺代わりで
あ、食ったらうまいんだ。これがうまいの
。だからもう1発で取り子にされちゃう
じゃん。これ名刺代わりで
名刺が俺も普通ね箸で食べるんだけど職人
さん江戸前だからこっちも手で食べますよ
ね。で、そういう気にさせられちゃう。
こっちがまずねお店に行く前に香水つけ
ちゃだめ。何しちゃダメってね、全部ね、
何条ってあるのよ。それをもう言われて
芸術つまりオペラ、世界最高のオペラを
例えばもうお亡くなりになったけど
パバロッティね、世界3大のパロッティの
最後の演奏ね、公園がサントリーホールに
あったんですよ。うちのか内と2人でき
ました。1人10万円でした。でも安い。
最後の公園です。そしてその後1年後に
亡くなりましたよ。1年半ぐらい経ってか
な。最後の公演だよね。肩にこうね、女子
の人っていうか人に手をこう肩に置き
ながらだからもう体力のかなりやっぱり
もう限界まで来てるんだろうね。でも
素晴らしい
テノールなんですよ。うん。素晴らしい
です。バレーにしてもそうだし、ドミンゴ
にしてもそうですし、超一流のやっぱり
歌手というのは
命をそこに使ってるんですよ。つまり芸術
なんですよ。だ、1回のその日本でね、
ドミンゴなんかは2000万とかもらう
わけですから。日本に来てやるだけで。
大谷翔平さんはどうですか?1000億
ですよ。契約金でも見事に活躍してるじゃ
ないですか。あれだけ観客を集める
力、魅了する力、人格的にも
全ての面で素晴らしいじゃん。お、俺も
同じ日本人としてはるか年下の大谷翔え
さんのこと誇りに思うよね。まあね、長年
花東
高校のお手伝いをさせてもらってきました
。立史夢実現プロジェクト
佐々木浩監督っていう人が素晴らしいん
です。僕は本当尊敬してます。26歳の時
にね、大谷翔えさんと僕ね、一緒にね、
食事のね、席に一緒になったことがいやあ
いやいやいや、もうね、26歳と思えない
ような人間力持ってました。礼儀正しいし
。こだわっているというか。
うーん。なんなんだろうな。1流と2流を
分けるもの。
決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容をそのものに
掘れ込んでるかどうかな。